hey guys how are you so this is the
video suggestion by Mike Evans who wants
to know how I'm gonna prepare for the
end of the world heading upon when
you're watching this video the end of
the world may be happening today it may
have already happened and it may be
tomorrow if you are one of the lucky
chosen few that are watching this after
twelve twelve twelve let me know how you
guys are doing what do you live and how
are you surviving anyway next to me is
my end of the world preparation bag I
put together a few things and the only
stipulation was it all has to fit in
this bag is really heavy now the first
thing that is actually not in my bag or
glasses well the end of the world
happens there's not going to be any more
prescriptions for contacts so I'm gonna
have to wear glasses now the number one
thing that you're gonna want to put
together is a med kit I have some some
zzzquil because you may have trouble
sleeping at the end of the world is no
band-aids these are gonna be really
crucial in case I want to feel sexy for
myself since there's nobody else left in
the world hair pick tampons even though
it's the end of the world let me tell
you what this will not stop deodorant I
don't want to be stinky Smashville this
current agile bottles empty so we're
screwed more band-aids okay moving right
along we're gonna need a weapon this is
the biggest knife that I could find I
don't own a gun
so this knife is actually still dirty I
pulled out of my dishwasher so doesn't
really matter it's the end of the world
now depending upon the type of world
ending that we have I mean is it going
to be sort of like a revolution style
where the lights go out and we have no
electricity I mean who knows but if it
is I have a game keep myself occupied
unfilled make the dinosaur game you're
going to want to stay hydrated the end
of the world so I brought some body
lotion a bottle of water hopefully I'll
be able to loot people and take their
water in motion because I only have one
bottle of each coffee the only bad part
about what I grabbed is these are coffee
beans not gonna be able to grind them
and only one bottle of water and I have
no way to actually boil it to make
coffee so I will probably end up just
eating these coffee beans
it smells great sunscreen
you're gonna need sunscreen because I
have a feeling that the Sun is gonna be
extra hot at the end of the world
flashlights like I said if this is
revolution we don't have any power and
all the batteries and everything just
doesn't work well this won't work but
you could also use it as a weapon
because it's gone heavy ah you're
definitely gonna need one of these I
don't really know what it is but it
looks like it could be used as a weapon
chopsticks also could be used as a
weapon ah this is some some spackling I
don't know I don't know you know what
that is here comes the survival
necessities peanut butter doesn't have
to be refrigerated some canned soup with
an already little tabby thing so you
don't need a can opener you know what I
didn't actually think the soup could
expire but I've had this so long that it
actually did in fact expire so it's the
end of the world doesn't matter expired
soup don't care a fork also could be
used as a weapon and if you're a fan of
Little Mermaid also known as a
dinglehopper gum
nobody likes bad breath yes into the
world's who cares sprinkles
no idea sunglasses told you man that end
of the world is gonna be bright gonna be
real bright um my phone is probably
won't work
ain't got nobody to call camera just cuz
these two things always stay with me so
I'm alone for old times sake I just
found these so I'm just gonna bring him
knowing orange headphones hand sanitizer
chapstick and last but not least some
sexy shoes because if I'm the last
person on this planet and I happen to
find another male we are going to need
to save the rest of the world so I want
to be
sexy thank you guys for watching my end
of the world Paul I hope to see you guys
in another video if not good luck love
you oh this could also double as a
something great alright I gotta go find
a place to hide